[Vsauce 2]
The MV Blue Marlin is
a semi-submersible heavy lift ship
designed to transport giant things,
like drilling rigs and destroyers.
Here's the ship carrying
a ship full of ships.
What the FAK?
The Facts and Knowledge
on Really Big Machines.
Bucket wheel excavators are used
in surface mining
as a continuous digging machine.
The massive wheel consists
of buckets used to scoop material as it turns
in large-scale open pit mining operations.
The Bagger 293
is the largest terrestrial vehicle in human history.
The largest single-bucket digging machine
ever created
was the Big Muskie.
The coal mining drag line
weighed 13,000 metric tons
and was 22 stories tall.
The bucket could hold
two Greyhound buses side by side,
and it took over 200,000 man hours
to construct.
Excavators are capable
of some ridiculous maneuvers,
like using one
to undress a woman
or like this Liebherr excavator
climbing to the top
of a specially-designed platform.
This is super!
[♪ music ♪]
Liebherr's T282C
diesel electric mining trucks are gigantic.
They can transport
363 metric tons
and have a top speed
of 40 miles per hour.
The NEESgrid is a network
of earthquake researchers
that use equipment
like these giant centrifuges.
This one is located
at Renselaer Polytechnic Institute
and is able to generate
200 Gs,
or 200 times
the earth's gravitation,
and can spin a sample
weighing up to one and a half tons.
To dig through the Earth,
tunnel boring machines are used,
like this one,
planning to dig below London
over the next three years.
The 150-meter-long machines
weigh nearly a thousand tons
and operate 24 hours a day,
digging about 100 meters per week.
Staying underground is the largest machine
ever built.
CERN's large hadron collider—
it's located
574 feet
below the Franco-Swiss border
in a tunnel 17 miles
in circumference.
The gargantuan high-energy particle accelerator
is being used
to test different theories
of particle physics
and high energy physics.
Accelerating up
to three miles per hour
is the self-propelled modular transporter,
a multi-axle trailer
designed to transport extremely large
and heavy cargo.
This video shows it transporting
two 510-ton steam generators.
It has hydraulic drive power
and steering
and 208 wheels.
If you're moving spacecraft,
you might want a crawler-transporter.
These huge vehicles
have eight tracks,
weigh 2,721 tons,
and use a laser-guided system
to keep
the mobile launcher platform level
within ten minutes of arc,
an angular measurement
equal to 1/60 of one degree.
For the largest movable,
technical, industrial machines
in the world, look no further
than the Overburden Conveyor Bridge F60.
This thing is used to transport
the overburden over the coal seam,
which is basically the rocks
and soil that are on top,
and this image shows its scale
with the Eiffel Tower.
The Falkirk Wheel is
a rotating boat lift in Scotland.
It connects the Forth and Clyde Canal
with the Union Canal
and is open to the public,
if you want to hop on a boat
and spin around
this awesome steel wheel.
Finally, the Midnight Rider
is the world's heaviest limousine.
At 50,560 pounds,
it has a bar,
three different lounges,
and holds 40 passengers.
I'm going to leave you
with this thing—
what is it,
and what does it do?
Before we go,
here's last video's winner.
Be sure to subscribe
for more Vsauce 2,
and as always,
thanks for watching.
[Vsauce 2]
[Click for more FAK]